[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
oh boy
I told you we found Republicans we're
gonna lie lie lie lie lie
we've already got an idea of Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan he's gonna open
up
an investigative committee and
investigate the investigators of the
investigators that investigated the
investigators
of the Insurrection non-insurrection
that antifa and black lives matter was
responsible for but all those people are
political prisoners all at the same time
it's going to be fantastic folks
it's going to be absolutely fantastic
he's also going to have a committee or
some [ __ ] about the documents that Joe
Biden has already turned over to Nara
the same [ __ ] day that they found him
his attorneys found them in a locked
Closet in an office that the former
president used
our former former vice president excuse
me the president the current president
now
not in his private home in his desk
drawer
so
oops
[Laughter]
uh listen don't get worried about this
documents thing don't get worried about
this select committee to investigate
those investigators that investigated
the investigators who investigated other
investigators because they're gonna
investigating now the investigators that
are investigating their lord and savior
that's what it's all about
every [ __ ] bit of all this
all the nonsense you watched on these
clips of Sean Hannity
teeing up lies for these idiots to whiff
on they totally [ __ ] this up I mean
last night they said that Ukraine was
our adversary
I mean
not surprising the Republican Party
loves Putin not surprising I mean they
love autocracy why not love that one
I mean it's the one that delivered in
some of their elections
in the last 10 years
I mean why not repay it you know I mean
Jesus Christ some of their members and I
like George Santos apparently are funded
by Russians so you know why not be a fan
of Putin
oh God Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan is this real
is it real life
then we're gonna have to sit and listen
to this [ __ ] box
for two [ __ ] years investigate the
doj
who's got his ass underneath the
criminal microscope him Scott Perry and
other members of Congress
not to mention who the hell is the
goddamn pipe bomber merger Taylor green
sorry I still got a cough
oh boy oh boy oh boy is it going to be a
fun two years
to listen to this nonsense now I
understand
and it's going to be a long slog here
to continue to talk about this but we
have to point this out I mean even this
morning
the computer system goes down at the FAA
and Republicans are are blaming it on
Pete bootage and Joe Biden that you know
there's a computer glitch or Cyber
attack Maybe
now the White House is claiming that
there's not a Cyber attack that's their
information they have right now who the
[ __ ] knows
this is the same stupid nonsense [ __ ]
that they got that they got out of their
that they didn't get out of their system
frankly but they try to get out of their
system
when there was a pipeline
down in the the the uh the southeast
part of the country Georgia to be
specific you remember this they shut
down the pipeline and the entire country
is going crazy these [ __ ] megalodites
these trumpers were pumping gasoline
into plastic grocery sacks even you
remember this [ __ ] like ice cream jugs
and
just [ __ ] anything they could find
they were pumping gasoline into it all
around the country not just where where
the [ __ ] the pipeline had been
compromised by hacking nope
uh-uh and the problem was fixed what
they did was is they I don't know they
fixed the pipeline
the computer problem where it had been
hacked
and they filled the supply with trucks
you remember I don't know if he
remembers do you remember this we were
watching video here on this show of
[ __ ] boneheads filling up containers
that weren't designed to have fuel in
them
some of them were [ __ ] plastic
grocery sacks and garbage bags in their
trunks because they thought there was
never going to be gasoline ever ever
again on Earth
that's how [ __ ] ignorant these people
are
the FAA has a computer glitch rather
it's a Cyber attack or not which
honestly if it is a Cyber attack
you think it's not going to be from one
of our adversaries that the Republicans
are willing to prop up like Putin and
Russia
come on
come on
but they continue to spread their lies
they're gonna do it
that's the only thing they got left
really it's the last play they have here
because this house rules
uh package that they passed is all
performance
theater none of it is real
they can't use those rules to pass
anything
you think they're going to get anything
done besides the the stupid idea that
they can repeal 87 000 IRS agents that
haven't even been hired yet
Lauren bobert doing a video
claiming that they've already fired 87
000 IRS agents or some [ __ ] oh my God
these [ __ ] scumbags the people listen
to these lies
they listened to them
without any challenge without any
accountability there are people you know
that you run into every day people you
think aren't dumb people
listen to this garbage and they believe
it because they hear it and because
there's no rebuttal absolute none
there's no one pushing back on them
saying hey that's not [ __ ] true
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
if you really think about it for a
second what you're saying is a bunch of
nonsense
and that's what we're here for
this is an information War
that we're in with these goddamn
fascists
and they've got a megaphone now
and they're going to use the megaphone
in Our House of Representatives that's
what they're gonna do
and they're probably not going to relent
I doubt they're going to back away from
any of these [ __ ] lies do you
I don't think I don't think Kevin
McCarthy's gonna have some come to Jesus
moment
decide that he's gonna go with the truth
from now on
really come on you think that no he's
not gonna do that neither is Jim I don't
report sex dimes Jordan
and you watched as Byron Donald's goes
on Joanne Reed's show
Joy just absolutely destroys him
and the ride's like oh look at her
getting destroyed like what are you
talking about
they're gonna believe what they're told
folks they're in a cult
it's cult
I don't know if you've studied Cults at
all or watched a documentary on one or
two of them
generally
the cult members believe what the cult
leaders
and the lieutenants tell them
problem with a delusional cult
now
it's a large number of people in this
country that are [ __ ] diluted and
really they're concentrated in certain
areas that can be gerrymandered to make
it to where
this delusion Works its way onto the
house floor
or these [ __ ] trees in this piece of
[ __ ] Maga Republicans is America First
Nazi party
has taken over part of our government
by the slimmest of margins
they fart in their margin in their
majority gone
oh forget that
but it is what it is now and we can't
act like it's something that it's not
you can't act like they're in regular
order because they're not
this is not regular order
to bring in a propaganda machine like
Sean Hannity
on on your first week of control
and try to resell the same old [ __ ]
lies
the same old [ __ ] lies that you've
been selling the last six years
of course they brought up the lamped up
Hunter Biden they can't help that oh man
that's [ __ ] good jerk off material
for these these Maga Republicans oh they
love oh God damn
they loved him some Hunter Biden dick
pics they love them some laptop talk oh
boy it really gets them going
nothing starts a treasonous circle jerk
like the words Hunter Biden's laptop
you know what you know what now that I'm
thinking about it oh my God oh my God we
need to get a hold someone get me Jim
Jordan's Congressional office in DC the
phone number there Matt we need to make
sure we call and we report that we think
we believe we've heard on the interwebs
people have been saying
because I just I'm going to say it here
I bet I bet there is evidence on Hunter
Biden's laptop
that his crack problem and his hooker
problem is the cause of this FAA
shutdown that's I I believe that the
laptop is behind it yep that's right I'm
announcing here on the Tony Michaels
podcast I believe Hunter Biden's lamped
up
is absolutely responsible for this FAA
shutdown and we should have a select
committee to investigate it
and we should put Dumb and Dumber in
charge of that Select Committee to
investigate this dumb idea
and it's a theory that I have because
people have been saying because I just
set it into a microphone you see how
this [ __ ] works
this is how their lies work
I mean you know I I'm joking about it
but you know someone cuts this clip
maybe people will start believing it
oh God damn it might be Hunter Biden
with a laptop somewhere who knows
don't put it past them folks so what
they're going to believe and what
they're not going to believe
foreign
if they believe the IRS agent [ __ ] and
that was their first thing you remember
Kevin McCarthy when he took gavel his
first thing he said first thing we're
good to do
is we're gonna fire 87 000 people that
aren't hired
and then they proceeded to pass a bill
that fired people that aren't hired
that's not gonna go anywhere in the
Senate
the funds have already been appropriated
the government already has them
gonna give them to the IRS
you think you think for a moment
But Chuck Schumer is gonna let that bill
go to the floor of the Senate and and
Joe Biden's gonna sign it
no I mean just looking at it is real and
raw facts
but they're celebrating it folks they're
like we're here we did it woohoo we did
it and I would bet I would bet within
the next few weeks if you go talk to
your dumbass Uncle Earl
he's got Trump flags hanging off his
truck
and ask him about the IRS agents he'd be
like well God damn they got rid of them
don't have them 87
000 IRS agents running around pointing
guns and badges at us
and back to Blue by the way
it's really stupid [ __ ] it's dumb [ __ ]
Jesus Christ I forget who it was and
we'll pull the clip
some stupid bastard got in front of a
microphone yesterday a Republican
secure and it was it Steve scalise
or was it chip Roy no it was Chip Roy
that [ __ ]
oh he's gonna be a fun piece of content
over the next two years folks chip Roy
is going to give us a lot of treasonous
pieces of [ __ ] content and we can just
tee up here
Jason originally posted this from the
house floor and Chip Roy
it's like oh we need to secure the
border and it's Biden's fault and blah
blah defund DHS
this is dumber than the IRS thing
this this idea to defund Department of
Homeland Security to secure the Border
is a dumber idea than to fire 87 000 IRS
agents and haven't been hired yet
these are dumb ideas
they're not based in any sort of reality
and the reason why is because Q Anon is
a hell of a drug folks
this is still queuing on we are still in
the throes of the Republican Party being
an absolute [ __ ]
fraud cult
and it's all based around this idea that
Donald Trump is the king
and only he can fix it
they always say we're obsessed with
Trump you're obsessed with Trump all she
could talk about is Trump trap trap
Trump
the only thing that is your existence
is that dumb [ __ ]
Jesus Christ why are you so scared of
that piece of [ __ ] being prosecuted get
him out of your way for crying out loud
God damn
why wouldn't the Republican Party want
Trump to be prosecuted and put in
federal prison for the rest of his life
at this point
the biggest [ __ ] loser the biggest
anchor they've ever had in their party
ever
everything he touches turns the liquid
[ __ ]
why wouldn't you want to lock him away I
mean make him a martyr be like yeah oh
yeah yeah we like him yeah whatever yeah
good oh secure the Border get rid of
brown people we hate gays I mean that
you know you could do that [ __ ] too
while he's being locked up you stupid
bastards
but they don't
the reason why is because he gives them
permission to be their worst
what do you think that where do you
think the hatred comes from
you think this hatred just all of a
sudden it happened no they've had this
hatred for decades and decades and
decades
his hatred has been boiling
in this country
in rural White America
and they've used white supremacy to melt
the minds of Americans thinking that
somehow their country's being stolen
from them
talk about a really stupid [ __ ] idea
as if this country could be stolen away
from [ __ ] white people as much power
as white men have in this country Jesus
Christ
get over yourselves
I mean on in this hand in the interview
or this whatever the [ __ ] it was some
kind of
Fest at these House Republicans had on
fake news Fox News excuse me news
just just to puke up their lies again
and again and again to Their audience to
reassure them that hey
those Lies We Tell told you
we're sticking by those lies we're not
going to the truth here
even though now we have to govern and if
we govern with lies it's gonna go bad
really bad
in that interview Elise stefanik
says that this Republican house caucus
is diverse
she says that they're diverse I don't
know if you were [ __ ] paying
attention
to the speaker vote
I don't know if you're paying attention
or not there ain't that many goddamn
women and there ain't that many [ __ ]
bypoc people over on the Republican side
when they mean diverse they mean some of
them got to pay some of them don't
some of them shave their old wrinkly
white balls some of them don't that's
the diversity that she's [ __ ]
yammering about
hey diverse the [ __ ] out of here just a
sack full of old white ball sacks that
are a bunch of [ __ ] bigots and a
bunch of goddamn America First Nazis
that's all you are over there believing
the Trump delusion
Q Anon as [ __ ]
but this is the disease that has rot our
country and again they want it
they want to believe Q Anon
they want to believe this garbage
because it makes them be the person that
they truly are at their core a horrible
disgusting vile piece of garbage just
like their dear leader
and they'll never get rid of him
they'll never get rid of him
they'll never Shake him and we shouldn't
let them
we should not let them Shake him
we should make them own it the entire
time the same way
I don't know if you've been paying
attention the same way they want to make
us own the couple classified documents
that Joe Biden had in the lock closet
that his attorneys found a turnovers
right away no obstruction no obstruction
no collusion maybe we should ah hey
there you go that's a nice phrase
it's a nice phrase
no obstruction no collusion I've heard
that somewhere
it worked for somebody
hmm
no obstruction no collusion with the
Biden documents
listen I don't know if you know this
either but this Biden document thing the
more they talk about it and I am excited
about Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan at [ __ ] he couldn't take
enough [ __ ] time to investigate sex
crimes that are happening against his
[ __ ] students at the college that he
worked at no telling what he did to him
it's a reason why he wouldn't report it
and he didn't want to get in trouble
link
[ __ ] him
and if he's gonna if he's gonna dig into
what happened with these documents of
Joe Biden's good let them talk about it
for months on end about how it it how
you appropriately when you find
classified documents how to handle it
that's all they're gonna do that is
that's all the facts that are gonna show
is that these attorneys these these
Liaisons the White House Council Nara
the administration
Biden himself is in the moment acted the
way you're supposed to act when you find
classified documents that are in a place
where they're not supposed to be
it does happen and there is protocol
they followed it
that's what you're going to see an
investigation of Jim Jordan the House
Republicans doing what they're gonna do
good [ __ ] them
let them do it
they ain't gonna talk about Trump
documents I haven't heard one
[ __ ] Republican not one goddamn
Republican talking about opening a
select committee into Donald Trump and
his the thousands of classified
documents that that piece of [ __ ] stole
from us
our government and harbor them down at
Mar-A-Lago because he's using it to
cover up [ __ ] that he did on January 6
when he tried to overthrow our
government at [ __ ] treasonous piece
of [ __ ]
that case is not about documents down at
Mar-A-Lago that case is about him hiding
evidence of how he tried to overthrow
our government on January 6 Bet On It
bet on it there's no documents casing
Trump with Trump it's all January 6th
the whole [ __ ] lot of it
why do you think cash Patel was involved
in the documents case when it first
started he was on TV he's like oh what a
prison could just declassify documents
with his mind and because they're
Declassified it's not illegal which is
not true at all
and if it's if that's the [ __ ] case
if the case they made
in the case they keep making about the
Trump documents is true then Joe Biden
gets the same [ __ ] leeway dummies
he's the president United States
he holds the office he's the dude
he's immune from all crimes everywhere
and anywhere Trump said it right if
you're the president you're immune
doesn't matter can't come after him
so they're done
but you don't see one [ __ ] house
Republican
gonna investigate why in the [ __ ] did
that [ __ ] sandwich down at Mar-A-Lago
have top secret documents in his goddamn
destroy and showing them to people like
Kyle Rittenhouse
why
what and why the [ __ ] were they hiding
in his closet in his safe and where in
the [ __ ] did the documents go out of the
empty folders huh and what documents
were they that's what the [ __ ] I want to
know and that's what the Department of
Justice is doing right now so was Jack
Smith and if you're out there doubting
what the Department of Justice is doing
boy I think you're gonna have
you're going to have a big foot in your
mouth over the next six to eight weeks I
really feel like we're close
Rudy Giuliani has got the stink put on
him the pressure is coming down
and there's these grand juries form and
there's more and more grand jury
activity in the appeals court it appears
that Jack Smith is going to go for the
throat and it's not surprising now
because Congress is seated these state
governments are seated
the 2022 election is over I mean even
though Gary Lake doesn't know it it's
over
it's done
they've taken office
which is the intention of the election
to form our government hours us
God damn it we're the government
stop acting like big government some
stupid [ __ ] building somewhere the
bigger we get the bigger government is
us the people
and to listen to people like that
treasonous piece of [ __ ] chip Roy stand
on the house floor and and chastise
Democrats to secure the Border
and call to defund the [ __ ]
the agency that's responsible for
securing the Border give me a [ __ ]
break
he basically [ __ ] all over border patrol
who are their best buddies oh they love
them some border patrol when a bunch of
border patrol are fascists they love
them they're in uniforms they got badges
they look like the Gestapo yeah they
like that [ __ ] and they round up brown
people these white Republicans love them
some [ __ ] border patrol that round up
brown people they [ __ ] love it
[ __ ] they'll get they'll get in their
tactical gear that they never put on
before and go down the border and have a
political theater down there
[ __ ] field trip
a Commando field trip for people like
Ted Cruz and Chip Roy and Lindsey Graham
give me a [ __ ] break you think any
one of these [ __ ] would last
two seconds two [ __ ] seconds in
actual situation
where they'd have to make decisions at
the border as an agent no
the [ __ ] doesn't even know that
he's calling to defund the security of
our border and they voted against it
time and time again they voted against
the security of our border they do not
want to secure our border
they don't they want people coming
across that thing over and over and over
again Caravans
they want the fentanyl to come in this
country they want it
it Causes Chaos for them
and their chaos machine and we're going
to see it over the next few years but
what we have to do is the pro-democracy
Coalition is stay vigilant
we can't relent
we have to lean into democracy now is
not the time to act like we won
now is the time to engage and engage we
will
and not get distracted by dumb [ __ ]
stories
dumb stupid [ __ ] that we don't even have
the information on yet like this FAA
thing this morning does it affect the
country yeah is the administration on it
yeah you can bet your ass the Biden
Administration is going to take care of
this just like they took care of the
baby formula remember that baby formula
honors don't be and then Joe Biden got
baby formula
never heard another goddamn thing about
it after that happened and the
Republicans voted against it
because they're the party and no well
we're gonna tell them no no to their
fascism and know to their [ __ ]
welcome to the Tony Michaels podcast we
do that every single weekday here noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch
make sure to subscribe to the YouTube
channel if you're new here do not forget
to subscribe this is super important we
are trying to get to 20 000 this month
so I need your help I need your help a
lot
not only do you need to subscribe you
need to share this with your friends on
Facebook you need to share with your
friends on Twitter on Mastodon on Tick
Tock tell them go subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast because it's been two
years of Tony that's right
January 14th is my two year anniversary
here on the Tony Michaels podcast I've
been yelling and screaming at you folks
for two years holy [ __ ]
and we want two more years at least I
think we should do 20. do you think I
should do this for 20 years just sit
here and yell and scream maybe 30. I
don't know
I don't know if I'd do it that old uh
but be that old and do it that long
but at least two more years we got two
more we got two years in let's get two
more years out of this sumbitch we need
it for 2024 to be quite honest with you
we're going to need we're going to need
messaging and narrative that is how we
won in 2022 that's how we won is you you
and your narrative and your messaging
and pushing it out there and
disseminating it amplifying it so do me
a huge favor amplify this channel the
Tony Michaels podcast subscribe share it
I appreciate every single one of you you
are the best audience in the entire
world I forgot my water so if the break
comes back and I'm not sitting here just
hang tight I'm gonna go grab my water
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show I got my water
hydrated I'm hydrated
water is so good I love me some water
water
it's the best medicine I think it really
is makes you have piss though for some
reason
oh 20 000.
people are excited about 20 000 in the
chat let's do this [ __ ] I think we can
get the 20 000 [ __ ] them why not why
can't we we already made it 13. hell I
never thought I'd get four
when I first started this show two years
ago
it was the day if you go listen to
episode one episode one of the Tony
Michaels podcast that is the day now the
audio sucks forgive me I've gotten
better at the microphone the audio thing
but day one of the Tony Michaels podcast
that was the day that the house voted on
the floor to impeach Donald Trump for
the Insurrection on January 6th I'm not
[ __ ] you I didn't plan it that way
it just happened
it's just how it happened
ended up being that day
so go take a look at that go take a look
at episode one
you can go to that at any directory
find episode one
you have to scroll down a bit we're at
episode what are we at today
300 and
the 306. so that's what today's episode
is damn I don't even know
307 well [ __ ] I skipped today
so we're at 307 307 episodes but the
very first episode was
the day that the house took the vote to
impeach Donald Trump
for the violent Insurrection the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup on January 6th
I remember that day you know why we're
reflecting of the two years
I remember the day of January 6. I used
to do a walk outside every day and I do
a video during my walk and before I went
out to my walk I watched that dumb [ __ ]
incite violence on the ellipse
I went and did a video about him
inciting violence on the ellipse
foreign
violence
in our capital city
now on the house floor
trying to equate
black lives matter
protest to the January 6. blaming antifa
for January 6th
it just doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
it's not supposed to
it's not going to
I promise you that
someone's bringing up Brazil so um we
haven't talked a lot about Brazil maybe
we'll dig into that today
um do you know that Brazil is just an
operation from Steve Bannon right this
is all an attempt to convince people
here in this country that the this is
still happening around the world
that the government there was already
seated there was no overturning it at
that point there was no Insurrection it
was a fake one it was a fraudulent one
because there wasn't even the government
wasn't even in session in the building
that they went to
so it was all for show and who it's to
show for it is not us
the people who are Tethered to reality
who have some kernel of Truth inside the
information that they used
to gather their logic and make decisions
about just normal average everyday [ __ ]
are not the ones that they're talking to
this was all gemmed up by Steve Bannon
and Jason Miller and Trump
in bolsonaro I mean he ain't got nothing
to lose to try to see if he can have a
coup attempt
now apparently they've called for his
extradition and rather they'll get it or
not I don't know it's complicated issue
it's complicated thing I know it doesn't
sound like it but it is very complicated
the same ways it's going to be very
complicated as Texas Paul mentioned
yesterday for us to extradite a member
of Congress in George Santos which again
if he's charged at the Department of
Justice Department of Justice is not
going to let that [ __ ] be
extradited no way I mean maybe
eventually
but if they charge him and the grand
jury finds indictments on George Santos
federal crimes he'll stay here to serve
his time for those crimes
before he goes anywhere else
but extradition is a very touchy process
it's not easy
it can be messy and there's a lot of
Court battles that go on
so maybe we'll dive into that today
maybe just maybe we'll get into the
whole Brazil thing but here's the thing
I think it's all [ __ ]
you talk about political theater that's
some political theater
now it had different ramp of they they
didn't really think it through right
these people don't think these things
through
they don't think through past the the
coup part
the part of where they grab power like
um you know all these insurrections that
is consid continue the soft coup that is
going on now
all the members of Congress the
moglodytes in Congress
uh the my pillow guy I don't know if you
noticed but that guy's probably in big
[ __ ] trouble too with this uh
deal out in Colorado where they were
[ __ ] with the voting machines
actually jacking with them
doing what they're accusing other people
of doing I mean this isn't surprising
with Republicans
you know they're like groomers oh you're
the child molesters you're pedos you're
chomos and they're the ones who are
doing all that stuff
like Matt Walsh yelling and screaming
about people's genitalia he's obsessed
on plastic Marauder and
tweeted this this morning she she said
Matt Walsh let's see
um we all know Matt Well's secret
secretly fetishizes trans women here it
is this is what I said I've said this
um so clearly obsessed with us I'm sure
his browser history would reflect that
yep absolutely 100 percent
that's what these [ __ ] sickos are
everything they say is a confession
it always ends up being them every time
every [ __ ] time I mean even look at
this document [ __ ] where Jim Jordan's
like yeah yeah you know we need to
investigate this
and uh the reason why is because make
sure they follow protocol which all
evidence and all reporting already which
problem that they're that
the Jim Jordan's gonna have with this is
there's not much there's not much
information on this found them they were
there they had the attorneys turned them
over
the White House Council was notified
Nara had possession of them as soon as
it could I mean it's fast it was fast
stuff it wasn't months and months of
negotiating to keep documents to make
sure that these documents didn't come to
light
so that Joe Biden could be charged with
[ __ ] obstructing official proceeding
on January 6th
and obstructing Congress and obstructing
the doj stealing of classified documents
I mean again
none of that none of that exists in the
Joe Biden case but Tim Jordan doesn't
give a [ __ ] about that he only cares
about his lies
that's all he cares about is his lies
let's do this we're going to go to the
chill list Roundup let me see if I can
get to him
see where Sanchez is at
[ __ ] list
I had to go get my water I forget the uh
send him
Rob Rob says you're obstructing the
obstructionist look
Republicans do not know how to govern
they think they do
that's that's the really stupid part
that is gonna be
really obvious over the next few years
they actually think they can govern
they don't know how but they think they
can
they think obstruction is governing
that's what they believe
obstruct obstructive structure the party
of no we talked about this with David
Bender last week
they absolutely have no [ __ ] end goal
in mind
it's only to appease the tale that is
wagging the dog
and generally speaking in a progressive
Society
the word no is flung around a lot
so the way that they govern is to
obstruct
the problem with that is it doesn't have
good output
it just doesn't
especially when your obstruction
is the one in the majority because
generally speaking obstruction comes
from the minority
in a legislative body right very rarely
with a majority who has control of the
legislative body obstruct themselves
it doesn't make any sense it's not
supposed to make sense though again this
is not supposed this this [ __ ] is not
supposed
to be logical
but Kevin McCarthy I know it I know he
feels like a
Charlotte but listen Kevin McCarthy
believes he knows how to govern and he
believes that the way to govern is too
obstruct
that's why he's like no 87 000 agents
that aren't hired
I mean why in the [ __ ] would you get
elected create jobs and the first thing
you do is say we're gonna get rid of 87
000 jobs
that makes no sense
you're obstructing 87
000 jobs that are already funded
why would you do that
the money is going to be there
rather Republicans are successful at the
IRS
um hiring 87 which they will be
the IRS listen to me the IRS over the
next 10 years is going to hire 87
000 agents thereabouts
they got the money they need the agents
they're gonna hire them
they've been waiting for decades for
Republicans to get the [ __ ] out of the
way so that the government could fund
their agency to do their job for us
they're they're they're the actual cert
Revenue Service
the part of the government that collects
Revenue
for you
why in the [ __ ] do we not want them to
do that
oh well we don't want taxes
well I mean I know you personally don't
want to pay any tax at all
and that's why you may be dumb enough to
believe the Republican lie that one day
you'll be rich enough you won't pay any
taxes because the rich in this country
don't pay taxes they don't pay their
fair share
and maybe just maybe
if we can all [ __ ] stop with the
nonsense with the hunter Biden's laptop
and the document talk
and get past some simple facts in that
debate maybe we can move on to things
like I don't know tax code
I doubt it
but that's why they attacked the
American people with the 87 000 jobs
that's why okay let's go to the [ __ ]
list Roundup game changers is going to
be joining us in just a second this is
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
and Dragons I don't think I played this
theme music in a while let me just go
straight to it we just don't have enough
time here on the Tony Michael's podcast
anymore by the way while you're here
before I go to the [ __ ] list make sure
to subscribe I'm gonna say this a
thousand times I'm gonna have to say it
a lot over the next several weeks we're
getting to 20 000 subscribers it's our
goal we had just over 13 right now I
don't know if the mods know how many we
got let's see when are we up to right
now like right now right now yeah yeah
13 248.
we're just over we're 248 over 13 000.
we're gonna get to 20 000 our goal is
twenty thousand
this week will Mark our two-year
anniversary here on the Tony Michaels
podcast
and our goal is to get to 20 000
subscribers on YouTube so if you're
listening to me out there on another
platform do me a huge favor
and I know you will because you're the
best audience in the world Hit the
Subscribe button even if you don't like
me I don't care
hell if you hate me hit the Subscribe
button you're definitely going to want
to come here and hate watch every single
weekday for two full hours because we're
gonna keep going for at least another
two years probably another 20. I don't
stop talking if you subscribe you'll
figure that out all right let's go let's
go to the shitless Roundup but we round
up all the Tweety tweets trendy Trends
as long as Elon pays his bills hit the
music start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hell the shitless Roundup where we round
up all the Tweety tweets and the journey
drinks welcome to this segment of the
Tony Michaels podcast my co-host Gabe
Sanchez will be joining us just in a
minute
to go through the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends I've got some clips to
show you guess what it is yes it's House
Republicans
yep
that's pretty much what it's going to be
the next two years folks they're the
ones that had the gavel they're the ones
that had the power and the rules
that are designed to what we just talked
about obstruct why in the [ __ ] would you
do that
why would you do that why would you
take control of a legislative body in
your first your first action well I mean
after not being able to pick a speaker
1500 times and then finally choosing
the one that you originally were going
to choose anyways
making a mockery of the process but why
would you
as your first order pass a rule package
that obstructed yourself I don't know
but Democrats are already doing a really
good job pointing out
House Republicans hypocrisy it won't be
hard folks it will not this guy Thomas
Massey you remember that [ __ ]
do you remember Thomas Massey let me
give you a refresher Lauren bobert and
Thomas Massey posted out pictures on
their Twitter account
Christmas pictures of their family
holding guns big huge automatic Rivals
woohoo they were tough they looked tough
they sounded tough and they're weak as
[ __ ]
what America [ __ ] white Christian
nationalist Taliban that's what it is
these [ __ ] idiots that's who this guy
is right here who's about to speak
now
he's talking about oversight uh
committees
in government
and giving oversight
for the government they're going to
investigate the investigators and
investigate investigators investigations
that's basically what they've been
saying
and Thomas Massey here is going to speak
on rather democrats should or shouldn't
seat members on those committees best
part is is the Democrat follow-up about
Scott Perry another treasonous piece of
[ __ ] let's listen
I implore my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle to populate this
committee with serious Democrats just
saying response okay okay
oh this guy this guy think it's gonna be
hard for the Democrats to find a serious
person to place on a committee
in the Democratic caucus this is again
these people don't know how to govern
they don't understand it they don't know
their colleagues and again a lot of this
is just [ __ ] lies
that they're spreading but if you watch
the house floor here
uh C-SPAN has gone back to its boring o
angles right
so typically C-SPAN will have an angle
of each Podium on each side and then
it'll have a out view of the chair or
the front of the room
and then any cameras on podiums in the
front of the room if they go down onto
the floor as opposed up in their seats
but Thomas Massey here doesn't
understand
the definition of serious I guess but
let's see how Democrats respond
foreign
to Thomas Massey not understanding that
there's a lot of serious Democrats that
are eligible for committees and they're
going to be on them just say in response
to the gentleman who said that he hopes
that we populate this select committee
with serious Democrats that uh that he
populates uh the committee with
Republicans who did not ask for a pardon
who did not have their phone seized by
the FBI I reserved my time
boom
boom
so
uh Jim McGovern here is a very good uh
and very good at working the floor again
if you watch C-SPAN C-SPAN is going to
be lit over the next two years probably
that's where a lot of these clips are
gonna come from is the house floor where
they get [ __ ] burned oh my God the
C-SPAN is going to be lit Gabe Sanchez I
actually sent you this video I think
last night and this is the one I sent I
was like hey man c-span's it's gonna be
[ __ ] on fire and George McGovern just
dunks Thomas Massey in the trash along
with his treasonous buddy Scott Perry
like he's done a pretty good job over
the last couple days even from the rules
package to like everything they said
during the rules package and the whole
like oh we're going to fight this idea
of 87 000 IRS agents you don't existing
in your door and they're like look you
know like I said yesterday I was like oh
thanks for bringing that up that uh
that is totally not real and I'm gonna
debunk it again right
um and Jim McGovern's good at this Jim
McGovern is really yeah no he's he's v
he's very good and you see it um you've
seen the last couple days last night
today it really is something to show the
Republican the Republican party is
attempting to push this idea of
misinformation lies all this stuff and
the Democratic party's like uh okay here
I'm just gonna fact check you right now
and see the guy with the glasses behind
him yeah so that's yeah I don't know
what his name is but uh I'm that's his
his Aid and the night that they were
doing the rules package they kept
bringing the Republicans kept bringing
stuff up and
um
was he kept you know he was going up to
me like oh this is actually what they
said and then they would come back and
they say what is the you know
representative from Massachusetts have
to say and then he'd be like ah let me
just read you this article that
literally quotes your own Republican
saying that you do have a three-page
addendum and that you're still reading
it right now despite the fact that other
Representatives on the Republican side
were like we don't know what this is
this is all big misconception this isn't
real and then the Democrats are like
actually this is what your own people
are quoted In Articles to the Press
right now right well and the one there's
a couple reasons why Jim McGovern and
we're gonna see a lot of Clips over him
over the next two years uh of him just
uh absolutely dunking on them on the
house floor when they're doing this when
they gavel in and the reason why is
because Jim McGovern if you look here on
the screen he's the rules committee
ranking member so not only
um is he the ranking member on the rules
committee but he knows the actual
[ __ ] he knows how Congress has
operates he knows the mechanisms so does
his aides
um that's the whole purpose of having
serious people in Washington to
understand this process not boneheads
like Thomas Massey and Scott Perry who
want to overthrow our government who
don't like our democracy and want to
destroy it that are trying to use our
democracy destroy it but that's why
you're going to see Jim and McGovern on
the floor a lot and the other reason why
is because he's really [ __ ] good at
it he can recall very quickly and quit
back and get a good rebuttal to whatever
the Republicans are saying in the moment
so you're going to see Democrats really
lean on mcgovernier a lot
um to be on the house floor and I'd also
say yeah go ahead yeah during the rules
package you know it if anyone you know I
think that you said you've done debate
in high school right and if anyone else
you know did debate like obviously you
have it you have your position but then
you also know like who has who knows
exactly what to say at what point right
who has the nail in the coffin who needs
to say what and during the rules package
McGovern was like I just want to you
know I wanna yield you know how much
ever time to my friend from this state
and then they would go down on the floor
or they would speak from the the table
that's off to the right of them
um and they would have the talking
points and they would say like ah this
person's going to talk about this this
person is going to talk about this and
they did a really great job Republicans
obviously wanted to you know push a
bunch of misinformation and stuff and
they kept saying the same
same lies and same uh you know untruths
which are 87
000 uh four hundred thousand dollars or
less uh you know this many billion
dollars is going to be allocated it was
just a bunch of lies and the Democrats
again did a great job and the government
was like and he's gonna talk and then
she's gonna talk and he's gonna talk and
everyone had their talking points and
they knew exactly what they needed to
say and they and they did it because
they only had like a minute or a minute
and a half or two minutes max or
whatever was yielded
um because this governing process isn't
just passing bills I mean it is a lot of
performance theater believe it or not
um and they and it's Time Performance
right like you're saying they have to
run their operation while you're on the
floor um one example that I'm looking
for a video here of Steve scalise
um um he he speaks over they they offer
an amendment they offer an amendment and
what happens when you offer an amendment
is the clerk reads out out loud the
amendment on the house floor
the reason why is because you would want
people to hear it right what is standard
procedure a lot of times is if the
members that are on the floor because
this is the thing that Republicans said
during the speaker debate they're like
oh we're not going to run the floor like
Democrats do our members are going to be
there give me a [ __ ] break now you're
not you can't you cannot you you can
only have you show up to have a quorum
and then you lead the house floor to
people who are going to run the floor
for the day right this is not and not
only that but like Republicans you know
saying that they need to they're no
longer allowing proxy voting which was
of course allowed during covet because
you wanted to have uh social distancing
and you wanted to limit the exposure
because God forbid you care for other
people's you know well-being or health
uh but the the idea that
um
they have to now show up they have to
show up every time they want to vote
which means Republicans either need to
get their [ __ ] together or they're going
to schedule votes of course and they're
going to try to say oh well well we
can't have it on this day because
so-and-so isn't there because again
remember that every vote counts for
Republicans right now their margin is is
a handful of votes right and that's why
it's so important that Kevin McCarthy uh
has to literally he's gonna I think Matt
Gates was the one who said it he's gonna
be in a straight jacket for the next two
years because he can't piss anyone off
right and he's going to be he's gonna be
walking this fine line where he needs
every single vote I mean even just the
vote that they had on the rules package
was so close so the idea that that they
can do whatever they want whenever they
want uh especially when it comes to you
have to be present if you're not there
that's a no vote so they really have to
abide by the rules that they set forward
and I think it's going to ultimately
bite them in the ass because that means
they're gonna have to show up and do
their job you know you mean Republican
show yeah yeah Republicans yeah good
luck why I mean the other thing too is
um I'm trying to find this this uh
because it's just a short clip and it
really it didn't have a lot of views but
again I I get into the weeds of this
with uh Lauren bobert not knowing how to
yield back her time
um that's the other thing that you're
gonna find with McGovern versus some of
these others there's no [ __ ] way the
Republicans are gonna let Lauren bobert
run the house floor for regular debate
no [ __ ] way I mean African way can't
even yield time back
appropriately not only that but also her
press tour little junket that she did
was a complete disaster I mean she went
on to Hannity handing her argued she
went on to Stephanie rules show 11th
Hour it made Nash of herself just
complete fool the idea that she was like
oh well tag or like constituents or
voters really you know really like this
and she's like they voted you in for a
reason you're not doing your job and
then of course Logan's like oh do you
want me to nominate you like are we
really going to make jokes about the
fact that you guys are holding this
place hostage and on top of that then
the next I think it's funny they think
it's funny they think it's a big joke
like that one guy who was like oh the
Clinton News Network like
or you're gonna say uh young lady right
like let's let's be respectful of the
people that are actually reporting on
the things that you guys are [ __ ] up
about and you guys can't figure out your
own [ __ ] right now to elect a speaker
and so then I think it was two days
after Lauren bobert went on to Sean
Hannity it was a day after then she went
on with Matt Gates because of course
they're [ __ ] so then they went on
there and they were talking with him and
and Sean Hannity was trying to save face
and be like we were texting after and we
were like oh that was good back and
forth and Lauren Bob was like yeah it
was good back and forth no it wasn't you
guys are now trying to save face because
you're afraid of what you guys were
talking about and the fact that you're
arguing and you can't get on the same
page in the same narrative shows that
you guys are in complete disarray this
chaos caucus this clown circus Congress
is completely just utterly a mess and
it's a complete joke and so now they're
trying to fix everything to be like oh
no we we were totally fine that's that's
what good debate is and it's like no
it's it's the fact that you guys didn't
know you're doing you were holding it
hostage and you of course didn't have
the votes and you were trying to force
Kevin McCarthy's hand and ultimately at
the end we're making secret deals just
like Byron Donald's got onto the
steering committee and even admitted to
it on Fox News
so it's like all of these people are
[ __ ] idiots and the fact that they
think that they can just pull one over
on us especially the people who are
watching this [ __ ] show happen in real
time is amazing
well here's Steve squeeze this is not
the clip I was talking about speaking of
pulling the wool over people's eyes and
trying to Gaslight us this is a good
clip but yeah let me describe the clip
to you but first I want to go to Dave
Paddock here on on Facebook he's really
upset he's really butt hurt that I was
laughing at Diamond passing away from
covid I don't give a [ __ ] man I could
care less how much hate I get honestly
he should be happy she did it to own
lives that's right that's right she she
did her good Duty as to own the lips
duty
duty and it's Tony with a Y man if you
were here long enough you know that I
think you're intentionally misspelling
it because you're trying to hear me yeah
Tony Tony uh he keeps trying to
intentionally misspell your name I think
he calls Texas Paul uh Paula he calls he
he fat shames both of you guys oh really
yeah yeah so Dave here has a lot of
insecurities apparently that he has to
come on here and do this type of thing
dude I look rather I'm straight gay like
men like women rather identify as a dude
or girl if you haven't figured this [ __ ]
out yet you've been here for a while man
if you haven't figured this [ __ ] out yet
that's a you problem not a meat problem
you dumb [ __ ] but the fact is
that if if he says here you notice the
hate for you from Rumble and Twitter I'm
not on Rumble am I on Rumble I'm not a
rumble I'm not on parlor I've got a
[ __ ] answer I've got a small account
on true social yeah before occasionally
I don't write in a comment yeah I didn't
I didn't even I even wrote anything on
true social but did you follow me over
their date why don't you follow me over
there Dave so I'm confused do you notice
the hate no we don't don't Tony doesn't
I don't we we're not on some of those
things so we wouldn't know that honestly
Dave the hate coming from you means I'm
doing it correctly if you're if you're
counting here so the fact that you come
here every day and
Tony I wish he would spell it with an
eye so I can imagine he's a girl listen
um here's the thing
is um Dave also I would imagine that
Dave doesn't just watch this lime on
Facebook he probably goes over to other
platforms and watches it on the other
platforms too
I'm sure someone else in the comments is
definitely Dave Paddock as well if
Dave's real name yeah right right well
Dave welcome and um I'm I'm
superbly uh excited that you were
offended by my words about Diamond dying
from kova that stupid [ __ ] and good for
her good for her that was her goal is
not to be vaccinated and get covered and
discover that it's just a cold that'll
kill you so yay I don't know what the
[ __ ] you're trying to prove there [ __ ]
her and [ __ ] you too okay [ __ ] this guy
that's on the screen Steve scalise so
here's the clip that I was um the clip
that I was trying to look for here's
what happened on the house floor Gabe he
he introduced an amendment and this
happens a lot Republican Democrat it
doesn't matter because a lot of
amendments for bills are really long and
most members don't want to sit there and
listen to you [ __ ] read it because
they don't care what it says they don't
care they don't give a [ __ ] there are
certain parts of a bill that a
Republican or a Democrat is going to
vote for regardless of what the [ __ ]
Amendment says sometimes they want to
change it sometimes they don't they
don't want to change it they don't want
to hear it now he introduces an
amendment on the floor what happens
in in the in in the house chamber is now
the clerk has to read that Amendment to
the members that are in the room
out loud so she goes to the the podium
she goes to the microphone she opens up
the amendment that was offered at the
floor the clerk was going to read she
starts to read it Gabe into the
microphone so you can hear her read it
Steve scalise then asks for emotion
almost immediately
and then they have to recognize they
have to the chair has to recognize the
the man from Louisiana Steve scalise and
what what says for the motion and he
says I give a motion for unanimous
consent to consider the amendment read
and reviewed and they say yay hey and it
just goes on so they don't actually read
it on the floor so here the Republican
party's posturing as if there's some
kind of transparent they want to follow
all the rules and all this [ __ ] they
want to make sure they read every Bill
the 72-hour rule as if any Republican
anywhere is going to read any of these
bills that they vote on bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] but that the posturing and the
posing and the political theater is all
nonsense just like this clip here
because this clip is bound to piss
people off and I love pissing people off
especially with Steve scalise get your
[ __ ] red up and really get some
strategic outrage because this one is a
bold-faced [ __ ] lie and he knows it
that [ __ ] in the back at least Stefan
that's right Dave I call her a [ __ ]
you're gonna go [ __ ] on Rumble and
parlor and hate on me because I call the
least stephanic a [ __ ] she is she's a
[ __ ]
um so here's here's here's these [ __ ]
idiots talking about lies about people
killing babies listen to this stupid
[ __ ] so if a baby's born alive outside
the womb in some states they actually
are allowing that baby to be killed and
calling it abortion it's murder and yet
it's legal in some states even people
that identify as pro-choice think that
that's disgusting and immoral and
shouldn't be allowed in America and yet
that is not a thing that is no I don't
know what he is talking about well
anywhere that allows that that is not a
[ __ ] thing it's a lie it's an
outright lie but here's the thing here's
what I want the audience to know this is
the reason why I play this is because
the decision that happened with Roe v
Wade really helped amplify the
Republicans messaging that they want to
take away your [ __ ] rights and what
they're do what they want to do with the
National Abortion ban because this is
where this is all coming from is a
National Abortion ban that the house is
gonna try to pass but it ain't gonna go
anywhere because Chuck Schumer and the
president United States will tell them
to go [ __ ] themselves yeah they won
elections too dummies yeah just like
just like the uh you know rescinding of
80 billion dollars for the IRS budget
which is necessary and it's not just for
people it's also just for [ __ ]
technology and to make operations more
efficient but you know God forbid
Republicans actually want the government
to work like a well-oiled machine
clip for you on that one oh okay chip
Roy you know this guy oh chip right with
the with the gray goatee
he looks honestly like this is the kind
of guy I would see like
at a football like college football
tailgate he'd be [ __ ] cooking some
dogs on the grill and he have his
[ __ ] his like Oakley like he likes
sunglasses is what you're saying he like
that one yeah maybe he likes the wiener
I don't know
um no no I'm talking about I'm talking
about on the grill man
I mean I don't know maybe the guy likes
wiener I don't know
oh yeah yeah yeah boy wants to you know
hammer down on some some ween I'm good
with it if he wants some hot sauce don't
worry Dave probably likes it too and it
helped Dave out over here deep Paddock
hey Dave you're our new fake game dumb
[ __ ] okay
um here's chip Roy here's this dumbass
they're yelling and screaming about
securing the Border have you ever heard
this before they talk about build the
wall they want to secure the Border they
hate brown people have you ever heard
this type of narrative before
yeah you would think
you would think that if they really
wanted to secure the Border
that what they would do is fund the
organization that goes down because
they're always like oh the Border agents
are so great we love the Border agents
people who dress up in [ __ ] uniforms
and Roundup brown people those are our
favorite kind of folks that get into get
into military style uniforms and
roundups and brown people you know
dehumanize them put them in lines and
[ __ ] yeah that's the kind of people we
like you think they'd want to fund that
organization but listen to what chip Roy
wants to do here to the Department of
Homeland Security is what it's called
and no uh camera uh you know presence
down in El Paso no going down there for
a show trip is going to change the fact
that Texans are struggling so it is time
right now for the House Majority to do
our job and we're gonna have to stop
funding a Department of Homeland
Security that refuses to secure the
border of the United States and we're
going to do that this year
so wait wait a second so he's got all
kinds of [ __ ] garlic this is the [ __ ]
you know yeah have you ever have you
ever ate goulash before in your life
yeah goulash is [ __ ] good but this
reminds me of of word goulash you know
what I mean oh there's just anything
that you cooked up during the week and
that was left over in the refrigerator
you throw it in a pan throw some [ __ ]
some spaghetti sauce and that [ __ ]
stirred around heated up throw some
macaroni noodles in it bam you got you a
goulash this is what this reminds me of
he's like Joe Biden went down to the
Border cameras were there photo op we do
photo ops love photo ops wanna secure
the board build the wall we love agents
we hate agents we wanted we want to have
security at the board but we want to
defund the security at the border I
don't understand what the [ __ ] he is
even trying to say well the other thing
too is during the rules well during the
IRS vote that they had on uh Monday
night
um to show you how much of [ __ ]
idiots they are
they continued with this idea like well
why are we giving 80 billion dollars to
the IRS why don't we just give that same
funding to [ __ ] agents down at the
border if we want IRS agents well no you
can't no you can't do that if you're
gonna if you're gonna defund DHS you
can't fund them all at the same time so
then it can't do that step so then
they're like well why don't we why don't
we send a bunch of IRS agents to go work
at the border okay all right
um uh all right look so there's this
whole thing about like specialized
skills uh and training in education uh
you wouldn't send something oh whoa whoa
easy those are bad words I'm just saying
education you will send someone who was
an unskilled uh uh you know
non-professional I mean though there are
a lot of Republicans so I could say that
there's a lot of uh non-professional
unskilled unfit members sitting on the
in the house chamber right now but
the idea that they could just flip-flop
and they could just switch them in and
out and they're like well it's a
government position so it's all the same
and it's like well you wouldn't just the
same way that somebody on the Republican
side would want to make a joke about
cops and they were like oh this person's
in Social Services oh you're gonna
you're gonna send them in for that it's
like okay one no they don't do the same
thing they have different skill sets
they approach the problems differently
depending on what the situation is so in
the same way you wouldn't send an IRS
agent down to [ __ ] Mexico or the
Border
to go guard it and make sure it's safe
for a for a wall mind you for a wall
that is unfinished and broken and now uh
Governor Greg Abbott is is begging
begging Joe Biden gave him a paper Joe
Biden read it and was like you know okay
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do I'm not
enough I'll do it asking for funding but
keep in mind that Greg Abbott used
taxpayer money to pay for the wall that
is broken that was Trump's great
magnificent wonderful wall that now a
quarter billion dollars is sitting
rusting in a lot somewhere because they
weren't able to actually finish the wall
that Trump said they finished it they
finished it is that true chip Roy's only
50. that dude's got to be at least 70.
let's see yeah [ __ ] um I I want to give
full disclosure if anyone's looking for
day Paddock I I bounced him and he was
talking about someone in the chat look I
I know Dave can't hear me now but dude
you can go after me [ __ ] me but you
ain't gonna be [ __ ] with people [ __ ]
you little [ __ ] so you're out sorry no
strikes no three strikes you're done see
don't worry I'm sure I'm sure he'll be
back
he will find another account to come in
and he'll be like not Dave Paddock and
he's like oh I'm so clever
uh chip Roy uh yeah he is 50. are you
[ __ ] whoa well I gotta go back now
what uh born
1972 on the day of August 7th so he
recently turned 50 actually this guy is
50 years old okay oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait I'm gonna send you this link right
now it's a Wikipedia just for this but
I'm going to show you that how much a
goatee
uh changes someone's look oh really yeah
so click on that link and just show the
image can you can you find
oh [ __ ] this reminds me of a boast of
some chucklehead that was uh elected in
a state uh State uh legislator somewhere
and he's got a big old beard I think
Liam Nissan made a joke about it see if
you can find you'll know it when you see
it talks about a shower drain let's go
fine man I know this is that might not
seem relevant but it definitely is gonna
be for sure you're gonna want to see
this holy what the [ __ ]
I'm just show the audience
[Laughter]
oh my God Eric look at this this is Chip
Roy
holy God damn this is what he looks like
without a goatee okay I don't know when
this uh here and to give context I want
to assume
that this is taken in 2019. so when did
he go with the three mustard when did he
go with the Three Musketeers look then
ah I don't know
um because this is his official Converse
picture this is the official one and he
because he he ran in 2018 right uh for
to succeed Lamar Smith uh who did not
run for reelection you know I think I
think that is is very new in the sense
it's only like two or three years old I
think I understand his problem he's
really he really is upset that
he can't grow any hair I think the other
thing too is the appearance of like of
of having uh having a goatee is making
him seem like he mainly or yeah man
because you know because you know Ted
Cruz grew the beard right take her right
now yeah I mean it took him a while and
he remember this Mega [ __ ] happened
they're like oh I get a group yeah if
you had the benefit of man well here's
the thing I also think kovid allowed
some people to like uh like go in baby
face and then come out with a beard and
not everyone had to see the awkward
transition of when I mean here's the
thing Ted Cruz is always patchy always
patchy so he'll he'll never get it but I
feel like chip Roy and I gotta I'll look
up to see when like go look back at
photos but I can I look back at her
right now when I see him and I say I
feel like he's the dude
that grew it during the pandemic and
then popped down it's like yeah I'm a
badass like he's trying to it's it's
giving me the image of a creepy porn
star but also the guy who wants to
tailgate with the younger girls at the
college football game right he's [ __ ]
tossing those winners
tossing the what wieners dude Oh you
mean hot dogs I thought you meant like I
thought I thought you meant uh never
mind here I'm gonna wait wait hold on
I'm gonna show this image this will give
you an idea this is when I see chip Roy
because he does this he does this very
often when chip Roy shows up and gives a
little [ __ ] speech from his little
lectern thing right uh a little Podium
and he's got his his tie that's like
little like it's like a a long day like
I'm going to the local bar to get myself
a shot of whiskey like that's chip Roy
right now where he's like look guys
everyone else might be still in the work
day but hey man It's Five O'Clock
Somewhere That's chip Roy
the other thing that happens is a lot of
guys will grow goatees
um because they don't have a chin uh you
know Andrew Tate that's why he grew a
beard yeah he just got another 30 days
in prison no [ __ ] oh I'm surprised me
surprised turns out when you [ __ ] sex
traffic human traffic women who don't
want to do that oh [ __ ] and you get
busted for also potentially I don't know
if people know this but Andrew Tate was
supposedly in communication with the
Romanian PM's uh I think daughter uh or
or niece I forget that I think it might
be a daughter but she was 16 years old
and was chatting with her via DMS on
Instagram and some people are saying
that that was kind of like the thing
that really struck the investigation to
look into him so either way Andrew Tate
bucked around and found out he just got
another 30 days in prison uh because
every 30 days it gets renewed in terms
of whether he can stay or whether he can
get released but for the many reasons
that Andrew Tate is a literal Flight
Risk uh and that's the reason why he
chose Romania because they're they're
more lenient on such laws turns out he
was [ __ ] wrong
uh he's another one of those guys who
tries to he was wrong in the opposite
direction does that surprise you though
with Andrew Tate that he was wrong in
the opposite yeah not at all I'm looking
for chip Roy I'm seeing a lot of photos
oh man there's a lot of photos of his
mouth open though here's here's this uh
here's this tweet I was talking about
earlier uh from Liam Neeson here it says
now this is a I think you're blaming on
the pandemic but I think this is a Maga
thing where it's the the beard is there
is there manhood you know what I mean
it's kind of like a Samson thing they
can't cut it off because it's their
manner you know it's what really gets
them to like the ween
um here he says it looks like something
you pull out of a shower drain 20 20 21
he did not have the goatee I'm looking
at a Fox News article right now it's not
yeah I didn't have the goatee in 2021.
it's a I'm a man thing type [ __ ] but
look at this guy here this guy is
apparently a new legislator and I've
there's a speech somewhere of this
[ __ ] oh this isn't just like a stock
image of a soil no this is a real this
ah this is this guy's real and he is on
the Q Anon I mean full on
he loves it
um he loves that drug but that it says
the joke looks like something you pulled
out of a shower drink
didn't that really truly accept I mean
have you ever cleaned out your shower
drain with like a yeah
it kind of looks like yeah when you've
got to build a bit of a clog and you're
like putting a snake through and you're
like oh God you're like God damn how did
that much hair where did that come from
there it is
I get his name uh there's a video going
around about him I like to show it [ __ ]
it hey we're on this guy why not [ __ ]
him
um let's see let's retweet that let's
see if I can find this guy's name so I
can I can figure out this because I
don't know who that is that's uh he gave
some sort of [ __ ] speech at his state
legislator and he started talking all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] of course is it just
uh
is it in like a Southern state uh
actually I think it's in Wisconsin to be
quite honest with you he won some kind
of District in Wisconsin and these
[ __ ] people are taking over these
places like that
[Music]
um
I don't know if you've seen uh I'm sure
people watching have seen this uh there
are videos on Tick Tock and and
Instagram where someone's like oh shave
your beard right like as a with a beard
they're like oh yeah they like look they
look real good right
and then they shave it and then it's
just no chin and it's you know like this
you know kind of thing but the beard was
hided the whole time because you
wouldn't know
and so then people and then then there's
obviously uh people who are reacting to
those videos who are debating about to
shave and they see the end result and
they're like no no I'm not gonna do that
I'm just gonna keep the beard rather
leave it unknown than than know for sure
I like to wear the beard and the reason
why is because then I don't have to
[ __ ] shave shaving's a pain in the
ass really is now the audience can't see
but I I have to shave my neck because I
got my [ __ ] hair grows all the way
down that son of a [ __ ] but the reason
why I wear a beard is so I don't have to
[ __ ] shave as much and I look good in
it I mean yeah I mean I can grow I'm a
sexy [ __ ] what sides mustache
you should do a chip Roy I should do a
chip grow oh okay you should grow the
chip Roy yeah I could do that
look I don't know if my partner would
really enjoy that so much you know oh
[ __ ] she likes the stubborn well you
know it's all also I don't yeah it's
it's when we first started dating
actually I had a I did the movember so I
had a mustache and I met her parents and
I was like okay
that's pretty good pretty good no no
wonder it's taken so long to
to finally seal a deal on this it
[ __ ] mustache they can't they can't
see you without it uh speaking of um
ridiculous facial here
um
Maven wessenberg and it's not Wisconsin
it's Minnesota Minnesota Minnesota
they way up North Dairy
um and not to make but I'm not making
fun of anyone if you even win
this guy
oh well any suggest in this clip of
jailing the governor of Minnesota yeah
this is the exactly
I don't know what the [ __ ] that means
what mandates can you see if there's any
mandates in Minnesota I doubt there is
but what the [ __ ] mandates is he talking
I don't know this is probably this
honestly probably has to do with like uh
uh distancing uh mask mandates and
businesses or the government maybe I
don't know this clip was posted on on
January 9th by the way I love that tie
well he's such a star where is he giving
his speech I don't know it looks like a
Kindergarten class or some [ __ ] but
listen listen get that close to a school
listen to what he calls the coven he's
not against vaccines
but listen to what he is against with
coven listen this is this is Q Anon 101
baby Freedom there you go uh you know
Mark said he should maybe start sending
people to jail because of these mandates
maybe we should start with Tim Walls
[Applause]
is America
the government doesn't get to tell you
what to do with your bodies
you don't have to listen to them and you
all have the power to say no
um
a year and a half ago not up here I was
just like one of you I started I started
a group and uh started pushing back
against things like this I started a
college yeah so if you're not part of a
group that is
getting the cult baby get in the cult
I'm not anti-vaccine but I'm
anti-covered vaccine it's not a vaccine
it's a death shot
oh these people are so dumb the idea I
just love the idea whenever they give a
speech they're always like look man the
government can't tell you what to do
with your body oh really you might want
to tell women that because that's
literally what they're fighting for the
whole the whole Narrative of white men
going government can't tell me what man
what to do like dude you drove here
right yeah I drove here in my car so
when you bought the card did they force
you to pay sales tax did they force you
to title it with the state did they
force you to buy insurance did they
force you to drive at a certain [ __ ]
speed and use a [ __ ] turn signal when
you turn and stop it and stop sign did
they force you to do it though but they
can't force me to do that did they force
you to pay the toll that pays for the
roads no Christ or buy gas and pay the
tax that uh
so because we can't see the audience I
have this idea that he's giving this
speech in what might seem like a school
but also could be I don't know his
basement somewhere and he's got like a
flag in the corner he's got like a like
a clap track behind it and so I uh it
feels like he's talking to no one and
he's filming from two different angles
he's like ah you know just a few months
ago I was just like you I was a nobody I
was a [ __ ] I'm still a [ __ ] actually I
don't believe in vaccines well I don't
believe in the covet vaccine doesn't
make me anti-vaxx though you know I was
a part of a group I formed a cult on
Facebook it's pretty cool want to join
it's also part of a multi-level
marketing team so is fake Gabe they're
in their boy they love that they love
that Facebook but that's what that
that's what makes me think of it makes
me think that he's giving a talk
somewhere like in his home and then he
just added a clap laugh track on top of
it as if it was a real thing and it's
like oh boy this looks even worse didn't
he I don't know I should maybe I
shouldn't say this ah [ __ ] it why not
why do I give a [ __ ] and then then he
look like
Taliban
I'm just saying you change his outfit a
little bit
just saying yeah
if you were to AK-47 yeah put a robe on
him I'm just saying y'all okay these
people y'all kaida y'all kinda these
people man this white Christian
nationalism and the you know all hopped
up on Q Anon stuff oh boy and then and
then you pair it with this [ __ ] white
male fragility these are the problems
that we have in our country it's not
deficits folks I mean it [ __ ] [ __ ]
boxes like this guy standing in the
kindergarten class or wherever he's at
the look that he has on his face yeah uh
and just that like that mic is just
brushing like and any any closer of him
moving to that mic it would become an
ASMR video hands down for sure but also
the idea that he's giving this video and
this look right now where he's like
trying to look into my soul makes it
look like this is the video that he
would release before he commits some
sort of crime where he's like uh here's
my Manifesto
my guess I love ZZ Top no no well I
think Liam Nissan made the [ __ ] joke
ZZ bottom oh yeah that's good
oh boy God damn
they make it so [ __ ] easy so [ __ ]
easy okay let's see sorry I got
distracted there by facial hair I just
couldn't help it I couldn't help but um
underdoggy Duck Dynasty wannabe you know
what's funny about Duck Dynasty you know
what's funny about that [ __ ]
that's a bunch of liberals they no
they're a bunch of [ __ ] boxes they
[ __ ] they're hate they they're Phil
got hate in their hearts all these
[ __ ] fragile white males got hate in
their hearts but those guys didn't have
beards until they had that show they
grew those beards and did that [ __ ] for
that show and everyone's like oh yeah
they're they're manly if you go back and
you look go go go Google Duck Dynasty
beach photos it shows those
[ __ ] just just just a couple
years before the show on a beach with
their family and oh yeah yeah I'm not
[ __ ] you
I would [ __ ] you gave Sanchez you're my
favorite turd oh my God yeah I feel like
we gotta share this with the audience
yeah sure well we're on beard talk let's
bring it up look I don't I don't want to
talk about the FFA
fffa you know and there's a lot of
beards there too maybe
um what is this that is this the that's
the photo okay
that's the Duck Dynasty picture without
beers before they were famous
boom there they are that's them they
literally grew the beards for the show
wow it's all [ __ ] it's all a [ __ ]
game it's a Rouge it is it's it's to
[ __ ] get you all worked up about [ __ ]
now here's maybe chip Roy saw them and
was like this is what I gotta do and he
was like I can't grow a beard and then
he's like I'll just go with the goatee
well These Guys these guys um and I
don't I don't think all four of these
[ __ ] are on the show I think three of
them are I don't remember I don't
[ __ ] remember the point is this is
their [ __ ] wealthy as [ __ ] they got
all kinds of [ __ ] money that their
dad made him and he's the one that went
into uh I think it was rolling stone he
did the the interview uh while they had
the a E Series Duck Dynasty and he's
basically like [ __ ] gay people I hate
them oh I mean so many words you know
it's the typical [ __ ] that these Maga
[ __ ] do yeah yeah and all all every
single one of these Duck Dynasty
bastards are you know trumpetites but um
but in in True Form and fashion they're
fake as [ __ ] right I mean it's like Don
Jr wearing flannel like come on man I
mean the other thing too is
all of them in this photo are wearing
either polos or a white shirt like the
cleanest I mean for this photo whatever
you know obviously is their family photo
and it's a super nice Beach we're just
hanging out at the beach
um but they're wearing polos I mean
one's got a Hard Rock Cafe Polo which is
fine maybe he worked there or something
or maybe he got it on the gift shop when
he was leaving mm-hmm the idea that
they're wearing the complete opposite
and looking the complete opposite of
what they are as Duck Dynasty
um is hilarious you know it really it
really goes again you know it goes to
the chip Roy the Ted Cruz the yeah Ted
Cruz changed his whole image too yeah
he's really [ __ ] fat and he started
wearing he started wearing the the the
the cowboy boots well yeah but the
shirts with like the Safari shirts with
a thousand pockets on it and [ __ ] cargo
pants yeah the um the it was it like a a
Margaritaville shirt like a yeah he
wears tactical they they they think
Bahama that's the name of the name Tommy
Bahama uh is that what he's wearing I
don't know is that what's that mean the
one that he wore when he was down at the
southern border yeah that [ __ ] idiot
yeah okay and the tactical gear [ __ ]
they think this tactical gear makes a
manly and that's when they were mocked
by the coyotes like the right I mean
they could have been mocked by actual
coyote like the animal but they were
mocked by Coyotes like the people trying
to get people across the border right
and they were on the other side of the
Rio Grande and they were just getting
mocked with Fox News they're like we're
on the scene we're gonna check out these
illegals and we're gonna find these
coyotes
oh of course the FAA is still trending
mayor Pete is still trending
um
because they shut down
the uh the air travel because apparently
the computer system is [ __ ]
um I don't know there's an outage well
is there any is there any update because
the White House was reporting earlier
that it wasn't they didn't believe that
it was a Cyber attack
um it just you know what probably
happened I bet all those really good
Engineers just decide up and decide you
know what we should go work for Elon
Musk that's what we should do and then
just up and left the FAA
[Music]
here's what caused the FFA ground stop
no damn no damn alerts are short for
notice of air Mission are crucial to
planning flights disruption ones that
was caused by an outage to A system that
the FAA uses to send real-time safety
alerts to Pilots
um this is the air traffic control
systems yeah yeah and without air
traffic control you'd have planes
colliding yeah it would be a [ __ ]
disaster created in 1947 yeah right
because they because they uh did the
right thing today and made sure to have
the system back up before they start
[ __ ] having air travel then they did
the right thing and they're responsible
but it also is fully restored so uh Pete
uh right they got it up and running yeah
it determined that the security system
affected by the overnight outages fully
restored in the Nationwide ground stop
will be lifted effective immediately and
that was just five hours ago right I've
directed an after action that's why I
didn't want to run with that story yeah
yeah writing on Twitter is a bunch of
[ __ ] dip shits are out there saying
oh yeah
they don't know
yeah I saw Jim Jordan he's like I don't
remember and now it is when President
Trump was in office and it's like well I
remember a lot of other shitty things
office like when you guys tried this is
Jim Jordan going to open up is Jim
Jordan going to open up a select
committee to investigate the
investigators or the investigators who
investigated the FAA I mean
investigating of the investigating of
the shutdown of the computer system
investigating you know I joke with you
and my sales Brothers last night it
really is like it's when you turn your
phone into selfie mode and you point it
to the mirror and it it begins that like
super infinite like uh trail of phone to
mirror to phone to mirror to phone to
mirror right and you move it and it's
like a little snake kind of thing it
really is the invest it they want to
investigate the investigators who are
investigating them for the crimes they
committed that justify them being
investigated
so that we can find out what happens you
know it that's when we live in it we
live in a hell of a time don't we it's
what a time to be alive it is a time to
be alive when you agree with that oh my
God yeah this one oh my gosh this moment
can you find me the bigger clip I can't
yeah it's probably I want the full-size
clip I can't find that some [ __ ] all I
can find is that one but here's what
happened Carl Rove um uh he [ __ ]
hates Trump uh and he knows that Trump
is a disease and he wants to rid the
Republican party of their disease
because he knows that it's going to rip
them to shreds and they're not going to
win back any [ __ ] thing in 2024
because the demographics are getting
worse and the lies are being exposed and
they will be exposed with criminal
[ __ ] charges but here's the thing
is again we mentioned it earlier Jill
Biden
in his office at uh at an Institute
where he had an office while he was
between vice president and president so
this is after he had come out of office
as vice president before he became the
president he used this office
attorneys of his who were on who were
packing up more of the office
found some classified documents I
believe there was two folders I believe
it's less than a dozen documents total I
think it's the reporting so far those
attorneys did a exact protocol that you
would do when you find documents of such
they followed the exact protocol has
been followed from the time they found
them and figured out what they were
until now
and their full cooperation Nara has
control of them they were handed over
that day the White House Council was
notified of the documents it's all done
appropriately the way that you handle it
when you find these things now
Karl Rove knows this and he points this
[ __ ] out um which one is this no no so
that's a we're going to bring that up in
a moment I'm still looking oh you're
still looking okay but that's something
else so Karl Rove went on Fox News
uh and he's trying to copy
Katie border frankly Katie Porter is way
better at a whiteboard and I would put
Katie Porter's whiteboard against Carl
Rose any day
but I have to hand it to Gar over here
I'm not a car rope fan I wouldn't want
to be within spitting distance of that
piece of [ __ ] of things I might do
um if I was within spitting distance of
him because he's such a pile of [ __ ] and
he's such a he's done gross things to
our country in our in our democracy oh
yeah but what he says here it really
makes me
um that's the link makes me happy but it
makes me cringe that I gotta agree with
Carl Rove it really I mean it really is
an interesting time to be alive here
when you're agreeing with Karl Rove uh
based on his history and his positions
that he's had and when he's the one
that's compared I mean it really does
show you that there are obviously
certain Republicans who are abandoning
Trump there are obviously those who are
not abandoning Trump
um but when you've got Karl Rove pulling
a Katie Porter with the white board and
trying to
and also he had the bit ready to go like
he knew what he was gonna say to explain
a visual and of course you know
Republicans or Maga is going to be like
oh Karl Rove is a rhino
yeah yeah well of course right
um so this is a clip on Fox News
uh of Karl Rove and agreeing with me and
me agreeing with him which is the thing
that I don't usually like but
um he does a great job of explaining why
Jim Jordan is a [ __ ] idiot here and
that's good enough for me so let's
listen to Carl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely
President Biden ignoring questions about
classified documents found in a private
office he used after serving as vice
president the papers were discovered in
a locked closet just days before the
midterms the administration says the
White House is cooperating with the
National Archives and the Department of
Justice regarding the discovery of what
appeared to be Obama Biden
Administration records including a small
number of documents with classified
markings the documents were discovered
when the president's personal attorneys
were packing files housed in a locked
closet to prepare to vacate okay office
space at the Penn Biden Center in
Washington DC okay so that's the Fox
news reporting she's kind of got the
facts there
um the thing that she really is brushing
over is that they were turned over
immediately yeah the protocols for
classified documents anything Mark
classified when you find them was
followed now my guess is this is just my
guess Gabe Sanchez that these documents
what he was using these documents for
was the book he wrote
um that would be my guess that him and
people who are helping him organize his
Memoir were taking these documents
because it was from the Obama Biden
Administration that's likely when a
former official has these type of
documents what they're doing is they're
trying to recall memories from stuff
that happened and a lot of times they
are in classified settings when they're
trying to describe these things one
instance that pops out in my mind of
when they would describe their feelings
and what their reactions were in the
moment is just like when Osama Bin Laden
was killed um that would be a good
example a lot of classified documents a
lot of classified [ __ ] around that
moment yeah but we've seen the picture
inside the situation room with with
Obama and Biden and Hillary Clinton
um the Secretary of State at the time uh
General Millie I mean they were all
there in the room so that would be an
instance where Obama would want to write
a memoir about that moment he would get
access to some of those documents so he
could recall the memories from that time
so he could write an appropriate Memoir
that's my guess it's what this is is
that this is something that Joe Biden I
I don't know for sure right but that
because there's not a lot of them right
there's not a lot of things here yeah I
mean it's there definitely are not boxes
full that were in a storage and in
multiple locations guest drawers desk
and in between showing them the kai
writtenhouse and MTG exactly look
there's just a lot I mean like in again
Karl Rove is going to agree with us on
this point
it's hard but here let's listen to Carl
let's bring in Karl Rove because well
this is sounds like he's finishing it
just right then yeah yes yeah well there
are and he's excited I can't make this
stuff up but there are differences for
example how many documents in Biden's
case there appear to be about 10 in the
case of President Trump hundreds how did
they get there we don't yet know how the
documents got to the Biden uh office
connected with his activities on behalf
of the University of Pennsylvania we
know that President Trump ordered the
removal of the documents to Mar-A-Lago
how responsive were they when when the
Biden people found out about it they
called and immediately called
appropriate authorities and turned them
over we spent a year and a half watching
the drama unfold in Mar-A-Lago and it
had to end in a police search to recover
the documents but still despite the
differences this is going to create lots
of headaches for the Department of
Justice in deciding how to handle
president Trump's issues because now
they have an issue that in least in the
minds of a lot of ordinary Americans are
going to be conflated as being roughly
the same that's why I think they did a
smart thing and turning this over to the
U.S attorney in Chicago to look at
initially that because that's the one of
the two remaining Trump U.S Trump
appointed U.S attorneys left in the in
the Justice Department uh that in the
Delaware who the Delaware U.S attorney
is looking into Hunter Biden but okay so
here you have uh Karo simping for uh Joe
Biden which honestly if you'd have told
me [ __ ] 15 years ago that Carl Rove
would be on air at Fox News uh
absolutely simply for Joe Biden and
saying Joe Biden's doing everything
correctly I just said you're full of
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's uh it's pretty
it's pretty oh what's going on my hair
man I just scratched my head uh it's
pretty crazy to to look at this and be
like this guy was the architect of so
many things that were bad right and now
we're looking and we're like oh yeah you
know what actually he's got a good point
and you're like what the [ __ ] well
here's the thing it's there's one thing
that I do disagree with him in this clip
because he says he makes it hard for the
Department Justice it does not
Department of Justice does not listen to
me audience
the Department of Justice does not give
a [ __ ] doesn't give a [ __ ] what the
American people believe is true and not
true they don't give a [ __ ] about what
they believe if this is the same thing
as the Trump thing they don't care Jack
Smith is not going to give a [ __ ] they
are only going to be bring facts to a
case rather it be Donald Trump and
documents more January 6 because
honestly Gabe I don't think the
documents cases the documents case
anymore the documents case is the
January 6 case it is no yes there is no
way that those two things are not
connected right but if but even but even
they're going to follow the facts in
that case they're going to follow the
facts in the hunter Biden case they're
going to follow the facts in the Joe
Biden classified documents case which is
not going to be a case same way as the
book laptop
as a quick reminder Benghazi
was run by Republicans Ben who who's
this Ben guy you speak uh never heard of
him Benghazi uh okay Benghazi took two
years
uh it wasted
some people some people say it was up to
40 plus million dollars with all of the
hearings and everything that was
included but officially on paper what I
could find was seven plus million
dollars but still is a lot of taxpayer
money
so when everything happened they're like
look
the the administration was like there is
no wrongdoing uh nothing we are Hillary
Clinton is fine like she's not involved
there wasn't any malicious activity even
Gowdy couldn't even trade
there was anything done wrong which I'll
bring up in a moment which is funny
because so Benghazi went two years
wasted seven plus million dollars and
found no wrongdoing right so the exact
same thing that Republicans were told
before they looked into her to be like
we're gonna put her through 11 hours of
[ __ ] uh hearings and all this stuff
and Republicans can't even show up keep
in mind there are
I don't know four or five you've got uh
McCarthy Jim Jordan Scott Perry and Andy
Biggs I believe are the four that
ignored their subpoenas and were uh then
uh sent over to the um the the office of
of congressional ethics which of course
the Republican Party want to gut you
know
um but Trey Gowdy what's funny is Trey
Gowdy called and just to go back a week
Trey Gowdy went on to Fox News and
called Matt Gates and Lauren bobert and
the rest of them a circus and a clown
show and they were misbehaving because
people had spent their time and effort
to elect them in November and now
they're doing this the exact same thing
that Stephanie rule called Lauren bovard
out for on the 11th hour and then Matt
Gates went on a Fox News and said oh
isn't it funny he should uh Trey Gowdy
should know about clown shows and circus
and all that stuff because they had the
Benghazi hearing and they didn't come up
with anything because there wasn't
anything to come up with you [ __ ]
idiot I mean that much money that much
time and and that smart of a dude Trey
Gowdy you should think they'd come up
with something I wonder at this [ __ ]
chucklehead's gonna come up with
anything what do you wonder this is is
that this is the um this is the whole
thing for today Hannity spreads Maga
house lies on Fox News News oh they're
[ __ ] jerking off to this oh my
goodness classified document stuff yeah
well they like they like to be like what
about ISM what about ism yeah no it's
they love me
what aboutism it honestly is uh it's
that all the time the craziest part is
Jim Jordan actually posted this clip of
himself now this thing's like nine
minutes long no they always like well
that's the point
nobody's gonna sit through nine [ __ ]
minutes someone can barely sit through
two minutes right the idea because
here's the thing they're hoping that
like Oh No One's Gonna watch it or some
people who do watch it are going to then
say uh oh man there's so many there's so
many facts in here there's so many good
facts in here handy really [ __ ]
brings it he really he really blows it
down uh alternative type ones yeah these
are alternative facts you know thank you
uh
I think there's a glitch shorter oh
there's probably a clip I'm sure there's
a ton of things
um yeah I think Aaron was covering this
last night on Twitter
um because there's also one of their
this at least have phonic talking about
the diversity of the Republican oh you
sent me that clip did I yeah you sent me
that this morning that was this morning
is that that was the one that is oh yeah
I was like okay this is it yeah yeah
okay yeah all right now I got it all
right now we're on the thread I like how
she says this in a room full of white
dudes right only white dudes
the only [ __ ] way they
I don't even know if they could get uh
their token black dude uh Byron Donald's
in the room for this one while she said
this Byron Donald's is oh man Byron
Donald's one on the joy read last night
he got his ass why would you do that why
would you show up on someone's show when
you know that that's what they're doing
here I don't know if you noticed that
but ever since ever since they started
on January 3rd that's what the bobert
thing's about that's what Margie Taylor
green getting back on Fox News is about
these Republicans they have to get their
message out to more than just the
diluted right yeah they're trying to
normalize themselves but what ends up
happening is that when they go on these
shows they're expecting a different
outcome than showing up to a show and
sounding like a [ __ ] idiot so when
they say dumb [ __ ] then the people who
are actually you know you don't even
need
two brain cells to rub together to know
that Republicans are [ __ ] idiots and
the things they're saying are just
untruths right and complete lies and so
when they go on a show when you have
people like uh Stephanie rule or uh
you've got Joy Reed or anyone else they
go on these shows and they're gonna be
challenged and they're going to be
proven or disproven and debunked with
actual facts
from what actually happened or what
documents actually said or what the
actual votes you know like what they
trickled out to be and they expect that
they're like oh no no I'm gonna I'm
gonna [ __ ] say this lie like I
normally do on Fox News and No One's
Gonna challenge me and then the people
on MSNBC
they're like that's not a thing that
never happened and you're completely
wrong now I I want to point out she is
going to in this clip talk about the
diversity it's only 28 seconds diversity
of the Republican party but if you look
behind her look at that diversity Gabe
Sanchez there's guys with parts in their
hair yeah there's guys
there's guys with white shirts guys with
blue shirts you got a guy with white
hair or glasses this is this is
diversity at its finest
oh my god let's listen to this [ __ ]
idiot take a look around at these
wonderful members this is the most
diverse class of Republicans look around
at these wonderful white men United
States Congress we have more women than
were ever elected before more Hispanic
oh oh wait wait oh there's okay okay
there's three women two
three the three members that they have
in their caucus Now show me women uh an
indigenous woman or a woman a black
woman or show me uh you know just
anything but a white old ring show me
someone who isn't white and then we can
talk and then even then we're going to
have some issues because I'm also going
to bring up the fact that you're you're
you're using them like you you Byron
Donald's Byron Donald's is the token
black guy he's just a prop to them what
at least stefanik doesn't know she's a
prop she's a [ __ ] prop because she
ain't there for her [ __ ] smarts
that's for sure listen to this bone-in
members ever elected before more
and American members in modern history
histos that our party is growing and I
will tell you the America First agenda
is a growing big tent agenda we've never
done better than we do today among
Hispanic voters and president Trump and
House Republicans were a huge part of
doing that what do you think Gabe
Sanchez I because we've talked about
this before
do you think 2024 is the tide turning on
on Hispanic communities absolutely going
well yeah yeah that's all [ __ ] that
was all nonsense and we got lied to
because they are they are they are a
tight-knit community and we talked about
this before that right right and uh and
they you know use their Rel you know
because uh Hispanic culture is very
religious and they've kind of tapped
into this Q Anon religious type thing
um there's just this idea of like
assimilating and feeling like you belong
and especially people who live in you
know the southern border states who are
like I don't want to cause any issues
right and if I played the game of white
white white you know uh then No One's
Gonna question and No One's Gonna you
know there might be obviously there
probably is uh whether it's uh so
subconscious or completely conscious
racism in somebody and things that
people say and they're joking around
that's just a joke man don't take it so
personally
and [ __ ] like that uh
uh it could be 2024 you might see a turn
I don't know I mean like you know I'm
surprised when I see you know people who
are from the Latino Community Hispanic
community that do vote in a way that
would be for republicans and Republicans
are obviously working against their own
best interest of you know actual
diversity and equity and actually having
a seat at the table I mean at least
stefanik says right here we elected more
African Americans than any before you
know okay I don't see any person in that
[ __ ] room that is African-American
show me one person they've got one two
three four women including Elise
stefanik of course they're putting them
front and center you know kindness they
don't want them all grouped together
they want them on the right they want
them on the left they want them in the
center but everyone else is a [ __ ]
white dude an older white dude gray hair
balding mediocre small dick have a
goatee hiding their chin that is exactly
what they are you've got [ __ ] Steve
scalise you've got Kevin McCarthy both
of these guys are complete cowards
who almost probably cried on Friday
night when the vote was nearly snatched
from Kevin McCarthy for another round
wait wait wait I doubt any I doubt Kevin
McCarthy nor Steve scalise would know
anything about the word snatch to be
quiet yeah no not at all no no not in
that sense not in that sense but I mean
that's what it is this group this group
is a bunch of uh idiots but also they
are malicious do you think it's smells
like sweaty old white nut sack in that
room
you know you know you know what I think
it smells like what you know mothballs
yeah yeah it smells like mothballs I I
have a feeling like this room smells
like mothballs yeah I well listen to
Sean Anthony here because this is only
15 seconds he really steps into here he
it's almost like he has a blindfold on
in a room and they're telling him hey
there's a lot of diversity in here
and there's there's not let's let's
listen you know uh congresswoman I know
you I've known you a long time
um one of the things I'd like to see and
I'm seeing is more diversity in the
Republican party to me the Democratic
party is the party of coastal Elites
oh my god listen I I let me remind the
Audi let me remind the audience of the
Democratic Primary in 2020. okay there
was two people running in the Democratic
party they were both old white men okay
Bernie Sanders who's Jewish and Joe
Biden who is Catholic now
I want to be clear on something
Joe Biden was counted out of the race he
was counted out he wasn't going to win
no [ __ ] way he can't win he's out of
money he's broke he can't get the votes
he goes to South Carolina
Jim Clyburn gets up in front of a
microphone Jim Clyburn was on the house
floor during the speaker debate he he
nominated Jim Jefferies at one point he
was one of the ones that nominated Jim
Jefferies and Jim clyburn's uh in
leadership he's been in the Democratic
caucus for years and he's a great
lawmaker he's a great idea
who did I say Jim say Jim Jefferies I
keep saying yes I keep I can I was like
who the [ __ ] is Jim Jefferies Hakeem
Jeffrey sorry sorry I'm getting all
kinds of names here we're getting to the
end of the show yeah we're gonna have to
end here soon but I got Jim Clyburn and
Jim Clyburn yeah that's how I mixed it
yeah yeah Jim Clyburn Jim Clyburn isn't
isn't he one of the offices where the uh
the emergency buttons were ripped out
that I think that is I think that's
correct with January 6th for people
that's right what I'm talking about but
Jim Clyburn in the 2020 primary stands
in front of a microphone and says I am
supporting Joe Biden and you
the black community should support Joe
Biden and in the in the South Carolina
primary Joe Biden ran away with that
primary and from then on
the the black community in the
Democratic party which is the foundation
of the democratic party they're the
foundation of the democratic party
Democrats wouldn't win anywhere
without the black community voting for
democracy they wouldn't yeah now what
Sean Hannity is saying in this clip is
that the foundation and the majority of
the democratic party which the majority
of the democratic party is now made up
by bipoc folks in this country
he's saying all those people forget
their religion their background their
race
forget all of it they're just Coastal
Elites right they are now relegated hey
can you remind me where did uh where did
Josh Hawley go to yeah well we want to
know where Sean handed he [ __ ] lives
you wonder where that [ __ ] lives
where did Ted Cruz go to school where
does he live where does Ted Cruz live I
know they're the Senators but I mean
they're of the same [ __ ] flock you
know so the idea that they're going to
talk about Coastal Elites let's keep in
mind that a lot of these people live in
very wealthy gated communities okay the
ones that they they have uh that they
have criticized themselves I mean Ted
Cruz went to the NRA convention after
Uvalde and talked about these gated
communities the guy lives in one of the
most wealthy communities in Texas
but these other people like Republicans
want to talk about Coastal Elites these
Coastal Elites uh no let's break down
the people that are actually
representatives and let's see outside of
the [ __ ] Mega idiots
um and some of them are gone but you
look at the rest of the people the
representatives and you look at them and
say you you're literally on the coast
and you also went to Elite schools you
want me to tell you the code words here
you want me to tell you the white people
code words I know what he said I know
what they're saying
there's a there's a diversity of people
there's white women there's white men
listen Gabe there's white men from the
state of Texas there's white men from
the state there's white white men from
the state of Illinois there's white men
in the Republican caucus from the state
of Missouri there's white men and and a
few white women from the state of Kansas
in the Republican caucus there's white
men from Arizona and if you're not aware
Gabe Sanchez the diversity that happens
when you get white men from Texas
Illinois Missouri a few women from
Kansas and men from Kansas and white men
from Arizona that is a diverse group of
people what they're saying is it's a
diverse group of white people from all
over this country and [ __ ] [ __ ] brown
and black people because they're the
coastal Elites that's what they're
saying that's the code words the [ __ ]
that they're trying to push that's the
nonsense that they're trying to [ __ ]
melt your mind with and mind [ __ ] you
and we won't let them not here not here
none of the dirty Michael did you uh
before we go did you play the the clip
of Santos no but I would love to play it
okay is that the one that you get no so
there's a click the Santos link
of his tweet and that'll give you
context for what I'm about to show you
okay so this is the uh this this is the
not the video I'm showing
no this is him I will this is him in
response because this is like less than
an hour ago
this is his actual tweet this is him
this isn't this is in response to now do
we know if he wrote this did he say he
wrote this and are we believing that he
said that he who knows you talk about
investigate the investigate investigate
the liar who lied and lied about him
which Nassau County County Republicans
are uh are saying that he should resign
which okay so here's his here's his
statement yeah
um George Santos writes well we assume
this is George Santos I was elected to
serve the people of New York's third not
the party of politics and politicians I
remain committed to doing that and
regret to hear that the local officials
refused to work with my office to
deliver results to keep our community
safe and lower the cost of living I will
not resign he doesn't have to he saved
Kevin McCarthy why would he have to
resign number one uh Kevin McCarthy owes
him not to resign uh so what's this uh
what's up that's the video this is the
video of him another elevator moment we
get a lot of these good elevator moments
um most of these have been Rachel Scott
right yeah yeah yeah
right some people say she's been good
about staking out right right I mean
like why wouldn't you man this guy is
everyday news he's not going to get old
anytime soon because the guys every day
that comes out we're finding new and new
stuff about someone on his staff or him
himself or someone else where they are
are complete frauds they're Liars their
cheats they're clowns and this is
another elevator moment it's almost as
good as uh as flake during uh the the
moment where he got a a approached by
two women during the Supreme Court
um confirmation hearings okay well let's
listen let's listen to what he doesn't
have to say I would I guess no no he
talks oh he he talks oh my God something
tells me he lies let's listen
here the New York Republicans are
calling you a disgrace
committee oh my God that is he said I'm
not going to resigned it he said in the
video I need to do a uh what was that on
him I have one I'm working on right now
which is a a recap of the more or less
like just the drama that happened last
week and also what do you mean with the
speaker mode yeah with the speakerphone
there's a lot more stuff that happened
in the background Trey Gowdy Matt Gates
Lauren bobert Byron Donald's these deals
that happened and also the uh the rules
package that they agreed on okay well
I'm excited everyone be looking for that
uh what was that
um also don't forget to subscribe while
you're here on the YouTube channel we're
gonna get to 20 000 it's two years of
Tony two years of Tony is what we've
called it and we're gonna get the twenty
thousand we're gonna do 20 more years
and I mean how many more years I'll look
like chip Roy at 50. 20 [ __ ] years
although I'll be much older than chip
Roy everyone every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific right here on YouTube Twitter
and twitch don't forget to subscribe
again subscribe subscribe subscribe send
it to a send it to a family member send
it to your friends send it to your
peoples on Facebooks or wherever go to
the YouTube channel And subscribe get us
to 20 000 subscribers
boy Gabe I know there's going to be a
lot more video tomorrow from these House
Republicans no doubt whatsoever every I
feel like every day is going to be a new
video that comes out and I'm saying
something dumb and then and then
Democrats being like you're [ __ ] dumb
same [ __ ] different diaper everyone same
time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon